[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans son caddie avec
ce matin le président de la chambre de
métiers et de l'artisanat de la
martinique henry salomon bonjour bonjour
vincent carry joindre aux auditeurs
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous inviter pour avoir les suites d'une
réunion que vous avez organisé vous avez
tenu le 26 février dernier dans le cadre
du grand débat national lancé par le
président de la république suite à la
crise dite des gilet jaune
alors voila mais en fait ça s'inscrit
dans le cadre du grand débat de
l'artisanat c'est à dire que c'est une
initiative d'abord nationale c'est le
président national de la chambre de
métiers de l'artisanat qui a voulu cela
absolument il y avait à l'origine une
initiative nationale du président de la
république mais qui ciblée sur la
citoyenneté sur la fiscalité et pour
nous donc réseau consulaire des chambres
de métiers il était très important que
le monde économique puisse s'exprimer et
notamment le monde artisanal
donc notre président donc de sema france
a fait une proposition aux différentes
régions de france de s'organiser
d'organiser des grands débats nationaux
sur leur territoire et en martinique
nous avons rencontré nos artisans des
présidents aussi d'organisations
professionnelles et nous avons échangé
avec eux c'était vraiment donc alors un
moment disent haut et ils ont été
nombreux à répondre à cette invitation
était une quarantaine donc à répondre à
notre invitation avec beaucoup de
présidents d'organisations
professionnelles donc ils sont venus
représenter leur métier dans les
échanges en été comme je le disais très
positif et très constructif et bien sûr
il y a donc des réalités de la vie
économique artisanat d notamment sur la
martinique qui sont remontés comme le
coût du travail donc le prix des charges
donc qui sont donc oppressante pour la
plupart de nos entreprises
le fait de travailler aussi sur un
territoire insulaire donc avec des frais
d'approvisionnement qui sont élevées
dont kurdes et des frais aussi deux
déplacements qui sont élevés donc là
aussi donc il faut que l'état puisse
apporter une réponse nous avons fait des
propositions
les démarches administratives aussi pour
les entreprises donc aujourd'hui et
chefs d'entreprises notamment dans une
entreprise artisanale c'est à s'occuper
de la production de la commercialisation
et la partie administrative et parfois
très lourdes complexe et là aussi donc
il faut que l'état puisse mettre en
place des dispositifs qui allège toutes
ces formalités et qui permettent aux
chefs d'entreprise artisanaux de se
concentrer sur leur production alors
vous il ya certainement des choses que
vous avez entendu qu'ils vous ont été
rapportés que vous connaissiez déjà un
vous venez de citer un certain nombre de
problématiques qui ne sont pas tout à
fait nouvelle et puisqu'il ya des choses
que vous avez découvertes ou dont vous
avez eu confirmation alors qu'on n'en
parlait pas forcément énormément quoi
voilà ce cas là je parlerais plutôt de
confirmation puisque étant élu président
de chambre de métiers et travailler avec
mon équipe donc nous sommes
quotidiennement sur le terrain est en
contact de nos artisans mais c'était
important de leur permettre de
s'exprimer
est ce que je leur ai proposé en
enrayant lorsque nous sommes réunis
c'est bien sûr il ya un grand débat
national
mais tout ce qui va sortir de nos
échanges devraient être aussi amené à
nos responsables politiques à nos
parlementaires à ceux qui construisent
l'avenir voilà ceux du territoire marti
noxon humain donc au delà de l'état il
faut que nos propositions puissent être
transmises aussi donc à tous ces
responsables politiques
alors moi je passe que vous avez quand
même je dirais déterminer un certain
nombre de thématiques pour cette réunion
vous aviez mâcher un peu le travail pour
pour dire ça de manière rapide et simple
est par exemple je vois que vous avez
noté un point sur le travail illégal et
la concurrence déloyale
bon ça c'est pas c'est pas un sujet dont
on entend parler quotidiennement ici
alors par exemple qu'est ce qu'il ya à
dire qu'est-ce qui a réclamé aux
pouvoirs publics
de ce point de vue alors on en entend
pas parler quotidiennement quand on est
en dehors du monde économique
oui alors ce que vous êtes
acteurs du monde économique là vous
allez en entendre parler et
régulièrement notamment
c'est un vrai problème ça se passe même
à quelques minutes d'ici sur le terminal
de croisières dans des salons de
coiffure ce nom des entreprises sur dans
le secteur du bâtiment
donc il faut absolument que les
contrôles soient réguliers que la loi
soit respectée que et bien que cette
concurrence soit une vraie concurrence
loyale et que ce ne soit pas toujours
les entreprises artisanales qui sont
déclarés qu'ils soient systématiquement
contrôlés et alors ce qui menace leurs
activités de façon déloyale eux sont
dans la nature parce que plus
difficilement donc contrôlable et bien
là aussi il faut qu'on inverse
j'allais dire le problème est que ce qui
cause bien cet or à notre production
locale notre travail local qu'ils soient
efficacement contrôler donc ça c'est du
quotidien
je vous parlais aussi du coût des
charges du coût des transports la
formation c'est important surtout sur un
territoire comme sur la martinique
on parle actuellement de neuf
organisations de notre jeunesse de la
formation professionnelle saignements la
formation oui donc la vision qui s'en
vont vous avez des besoins en formation
des apprentis artisans c'est ça on a
beaucoup de jeunes qui quittent le
territoire ont pour aller tenter leur
chance ailleurs aller trouver un travail
ailleurs où aller se former ailleurs il
faut qu'on puisse former un maximum de
jeunes martiniquais sur le territoire
martiniquais parce qu'il ya des besoins
en martinique il ya des emplois
d'aujourd'hui mais aussi les emplois de
demain
donc il faut des centres de formation
qui soit adaptée qu'ils soient modernes
qui permettent de préparer donc les 10
20 années à venir en terme de formation
il faut aussi que nos artisans puissent
être formés nous avons un gros déficit
en formation est souvent lorsque vous
avez besoin d'une formation d'une
expertise vous êtes obligé de partir et
ça c'est un coup et non pour une
entreprise artisanale et même pour un
autre type d'entreprise
mais là aussi il faut qu'on assure une
équité ça coûte plus cher d'être
j'allais dire entrepreneurs artisans sur
une intérieure insulaires en martinique
eh bien il faut que l'état puisse
compenser ces différences hypo qu'on
puisse pouvoir se déplacer pour nos
formations
sans avoir en partie en pâtir
financièrement donc il faut vraiment
qu'il est l'accompagnement financier de
ces chefs d'entreprise qui veulent se
former pour plus de compétences il nous
reste peu de temps réfalo mon président
de la chambre de métiers et de
l'artisanat de martinique encore deux
questions pour souligner d'abord que
vous vous êtes finalement rassemblé
aussi entre un certain nombre de
d'organisations professionnelles
donc il y à celle que vous présidez la
chambre de métiers mais aussi avec
d'autres tels que contact entreprises le
réseau entreprendre martinique
la fédération des très petites
entreprises ou encore la hem pays réunis
sous la bannière martinique économique
et vous avez proposé vous avez fait des
propositions fortes aussi justement vous
êtes rassemblés
absolument c'est très important alors
pourquoi se rassembler parce que l'union
fait la force
aujourd'hui le monde économique doit
pouvoir parler d'une même voix
et ça je trouve ça fantastique et je
salue donc tous les acteurs de ce
rassemblement qui se sont mis autour
d'une table pour partager puisqu'il y
avait eu des séquences et échange du
grand débat national
nous avons pu donc bien partager nos
opinions et nous avons vu qu'il y avait
beaucoup de points communs notamment sur
le coût du travail est l'une des
propositions et qui est vraiment une
proposition très très très forte et la
détaxe du travail c'est à dire supprimer
les charges salariales et patronales sur
l'ensemble des salaires alors qu'est ce
que ça va provoquer ça a provoqué que ça
va être beaucoup plus facile de recruter
non on va lutter efficacement contre le
chômage endémique à la martinique
notamment chez nos jeunes
on va donc d'en créer de l'activité n'en
crée de la richesse ça veut dire des
indes entreprises qui vont pouvoir payer
des impôts des salariés aussi qu'ils
seront mieux payés donc on va augmenter
le pouvoir d'achat parce que si on a
moins de charges a donné la victoire à
l'âge de 40 ans il nous reste une minute
quand vous dites des taxes et vous
demande est en fait une exonération
totale des charges patronales et des
charges salariales un point et on pourra
dire que c'est révolutionnaire mais l
état aura à y gagner
et pourquoi nous demandons ceci aussi
c'est parce qu'il ya un vrai déficit
structurel d'aidé et un déficit aussi en
investissements de l'état et ça remonte
à des années sur la martinique
c'est une façon de compenser cette
guerre des taxes complète du travail
pour relancer l'activité pour que on ait
envie d'embaucher leur flambée avait de
l'activité et surtout pour augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat pour conclure en
quelques mots donc toutes ces
contributions vont être transmises au
gouvernement ainsi qu'à la commission
nationale du débat public
vous vous engagez à faire le suivi vous
et vous aviez suivi doit être au niveau
du gouvernement mais aussi au niveau
régional et il y aura encore d'autres
sujets à partager ensemble parce que le
monde économique peut vraiment apporter
des solutions développement de la q2 de
la martinique c'est essentiel il faut
pouvoir travailler et vivre en
martinique
merci henri salomon président de la
chambre de métiers de l'artisanat de
martinique d'avoir participé participer
excusez moi à ce saout a dit bonne
journée
restez à l'écouté de nos programmes